in der Stadt Nikolaev in der Ukraine
Aber das war vor dem Krieg
Ich bin 32 geboren
[Musik]
Wir verließen es, als es anfing
Plötzlich beginnt der Krieg wieder, oh du für
Ich hatte große Angst, weil ich schon
Ich habe es geschafft, all dies zu übertragen, und ich denke, wenn
es fängt alles von vorne an, was kümmert es mich
Nun, was habe ich in meinem Leben getan und nicht
nur ich will, dass das wieder passiert
Kiew wird auch verschwinden Produkte und
sehr schnell
Haben Sie jemals damit gerechnet, dass Russland es tun könnte?
Greife die Ukraine niemals an
Lehrer der russischen Sprache der Literatur
kannst du dir vorstellen, dass ich könnte
Überlege, ob ich aufs College gehe
Russland wusste das natürlich nicht
Russischlehrer u
Literatur was meint ihr
dass Putin beschloss, die Ukraine anzugreifen
Sie wissen, es ist sehr schwer zu beurteilen
Es ist überhaupt nicht normal, um ehrlich zu sein
Von Gut aus zu urteilen
aus der Sicht eines gewöhnlichen Menschen, dass seine
also ich habe den eindruck, dass er
hallo weil
die Ukraine praktisch von ihm angreifen
kein Grund
Er sagt, dies sei die Entnazifizierung der Ukraine
Verstehst du, verstehst du ihn?
behauptet im Allgemeinen, dass in der Ukraine
schierer Faschismus, aber das stimmt nicht
Zum Beispiel lebe ich in der Ukraine. Wie viel
Jahren und irgendwie
irgendwie ging es mich nichts an, das ist alles
ist mir als Kind passiert
Ich wurde wegen meiner Nationalität geschlagen und angeschrien
danach war es die Region Astrachan
Schrei nicht das Licht, wer bin ich
Ich wurde von der Schulleitung gemobbt
Ich will nach Israel
Wenn möglich
[Musik]
Putin
Putin, fick dich selbst
das ist schrecklich
Ich möchte wirklich zu meiner Geliebten zurückkehren
Kiew
[Musik]
Familien-oder Nachname
landet